well the Bellagio is all decked out for  the holidays now they've made a festive  change for the holiday season the new  display it's called gingerbread dreams a  holiday confection the winter display  features a 42 foot tall white fir tree  and a gingerbread Cottage there are more  than 15  000 gingerbread men and women throughout  the display I made that part up I just  expect that there would be gingerbread  women in their books and women yeah why  not they're polar bears for sure  always pretty inside there bringing all  the lights and all the oh the polar  bears are magical I just love it love it  so pretty and it's free yeah it is free  and then you go gamble and drink and  then